welcome to Hannity big breaking and
perhaps hopefully hopefully
game-changing news tonight the red tape
has been cut the FDA's acting the
president is acting all at unprecedented
speed and America's top scientists
medical researchers doctors are now
working around the clock on new major
breakthrough ways to treat the corona
virus actually using medicines that are
FDA approved and already in use we have
these incredible details coming up
tonight three separate areas we're
working on right now and we're also in
the midst of a major worldwide pandemic
sadly this full-blown global crisis
might have been prevented or at least
mitigated if not for the corrupt
actions of the Communist Chinese
government according to this top study
from a British University 95% of all
corona virus cases may have in fact been
prevented if China didn't try to hide
and cover up this deadly disease at
every important moment and as the
president indicated earlier today
they've been saying it really more
loudly than I anyone else I can think of
China cannot be trusted take a look
China they reported for the first time
since the outbreak no new cases over a
24-hour period do you have any reason to
disbelieve them as far as believing what
they're putting out now I hope it's true
who knows but I hope it's true are you
thinking about any types of
repercussions for China and are you also
rethinking sort of the supply lines for
our manufacturing industry I don't want
to comment on that right now
sadly we can't trust anything coming
from China's government so here are the
facts as early as December high-ranking
Chinese officials they actually silence
the doctors on the front lines and the
journalists you even can say they have
journalists they don't have freedom of
the press who bravely tried to tell the
truth to the entire world
give the important information vital
information to the world about the
corona virus now many of those doctors
who put their lives at risk they are
dead they died trying to save others in
their country and worldwide and on
January 18th when the disease was
rapidly
spreading in the Wuhan province of China
while the city hosted a massive potluck
dinner with tens of thousands of
attendees beyond it's incomprehensible
how dumb that is wasn't until January
20th after the virus already spread all
over the world the China actually
admitted the disease was contagious
person-to-person now the 21st of January
we had our first known case here the
31st ten days later that was the travel
ban getting to that in a second this is
the kind of botched Chernobyl like
cover-up
sadly predictable for communist
governments doesn't mean we shouldn't
get along with them but we need to know
that they're hostile actors they didn't
act alone the world's health
organization everybody needs to know
this they are a corrupt and frankly
useless organization not unlike the
United Nations from my perspective they
were supposed to be an organization the
world could trust instead they have been
doing is all they've been doing is
spreading Chinese Communist Party
propaganda from day one they haven't
done any independent fact-checking and
they deserve blame for this as those
China look at this January 14th that's
late in the game by this point World
Health Organization tweets quote Chinese
authorities have found no clear evidence
of human-to-human transmission of the
virus if they had any sense they would
have known that's not true they done
their own research they would have known
in five minutes that's not true
WH OHS director and general and chief is
a pretty sketchy individual no medical
training he's been carrying China's
water for months on this according to a
brand new report in the hill tonight he
turned a blind eye to what has happened
in Wuhan and the rest of China after
meeting with President Xi in January and
quote from the outset he defended China
despite its gross mismanagement of the
highly contagious disease even
suggesting that the president's travel
ban to and from China was racist that
one decision history will bear this out
10 days after the first identified case
in this country January 21st first case
January 31st travel ban
that one decision did more to protect
the health and lives of American
citizens than any one thing that has
happened thousands and thousands of more
Americans would have contracted this
virus and it is incalculable
how many more Americans would have died
exponentially we would have been in a
far worse position than we are now and
how sad is your mob and the media do
they ever give the president credit in
retrospect president was right with that
don't hold your breath
same with the Democrats dr. Joe Biden
that very day that the president
implemented that travel ban all this is
what he had to say take a look and I was
like this this is where credibly a
president is most needed as he explains
what we should and should not do this is
no time for Donald Trump's record of
hysteria xenophobia hysterical
xenophobia too and fear-mongering to
lead the way instead of science
hysterical xenophobia fear my wake up
Joe what's even worse though is even
knowing what we now know this is even
worse you know dr. quid-pro-quo says he
would not have implemented the ban like
everything else this man does he is
clueless with zero awareness stuck in
that swab style thinking and stupidity
and now that brand of identity politics
is like the new favorite tactic of
China's propaganda department which is
now working overtime to deflect blame
now other frequently used disinformation
campaigns include a conspiracy theory
that US troops are responsible for the
Chinese coronavirus that is a lie that
is an outright lie
China's oppressive regime caused
hundreds of thousands worldwide to get
sick it has caused sickness death and
destruction for thousands and thousands
more they must be held accountable and
by the way another is laughable they
claim that more propaganda
they're now claiming that they're
leading the way worldwide in the fight
against the virus even though they're
the ones that covered it up all these
months unfortunately
Democrats and of course the gullible
medium mob that just hate President
Trump so much yeah now echoing these
ridiculous Chinese lies and propaganda
including yeah former Obama national
security adviser the genius that she is
Susan Rice take a look China is not
behaving well in trying to blame this on
the United States but the flip side of
it is we are not behaving well when we
talk about as the President does every
day
the Chinese virus the Wuhan flu and all
of these racist
descriptions really Susan Susan Rice
what are the single least trustworthy
individuals on the face of the earth a
national disgrace remember five sunday
shows blatant lies after the Benghazi
attacks that will never be forgotten
good rule-of-thumb with Susan Rice
whatever she says believe the opposite
but I digress
now the media mob their new favorite
hysteria centers around a picture from a
Washington Post photographer showing an
up-close shot of the president's notes
where Coronas crossed out replaced with
Chinese Business Insider article
suggesting that he was using racism
against China to try and distract from
the president's disastrous coronavirus
response fake news CNN called it
inaccurate stigmatizing thousands of
Americans will be sick and die and this
is what they focused on really because
we have all sorts of diseases we laid
them out last night
named after the location where they are
discovered more lying to their viewers
because of course their agendas to hate
the president even willing dupes to
spread Chinese propaganda it is pathetic
and today President Trump had a message
for his friends and the media mob take a
look so why was the United States not
happy we were very prepared the only
thing we weren't prepared for was the
the media the media has not treated it
fairly I'll tell you how prepared I was
I called for a ban from people coming in
from China long before anybody thought
it was in fact it was your network I
believe they called me a racist because
I did that
it was many of the people in the room
they call me racist and other words
because I did that because I went so
early so when you say we weren't
prepared had I let these tens of
thousands of people come in from China a
day we would have had something right
now that would have been you wouldn't
have even recognized it compared to
where we are extremely well said here
are some facts that the mob won't report
you know the ones that the New York
Times oh I just love the New York time
Trump virus if you're feeling awful you
know who to blame oh and president has a
call with governors Oh president says
you're on your own
no he said if you can do it faster do it
we've have your back they forgot that
part that is called edited fake news now
thanks to the president's decisive
actions a new precedent has been set I
call this a paradigm shift going forward
future pandemics
unfortunately they pop up I wish they
didn't travel bans will now be used
quickly to slow the spread of the
disease because it saves lives of
Americans the success of the president's
public-private partnership surrounding
testing another new massive paradigm
shift they're doing all of this on the
fly in record time keeping people out of
hospitals that will be how things work
going forward tell up medicine my son
has a fever my daughter has a fever take
a look at my son or daughter what do I
do do I need to go to the emergency room
well not now but call me back in an hour
and you face time again now the United
States is actively looking for ways to
decrease our dependency on important
Goods and medicines manufactured in
China you know what we can't afford to
risk this any further
now the person has been warning us about
China that one person for the longest
time President Trump he's been right all
along